übrigens freunde wollte eigentlich dass
johann livestream mache also ich würde
dann heute abend ein bisschen heroes
stream wir wahrscheinlich nur dann eine
stunde oder zwei stunden hero ich muss
mir doch mal durchlesen videospielen
regeln da sind aber wer die erst mal
dafür schreibt man kommentare ob ihr ja
schreibt für leistung und nein
mit ganz vielen und ii und enden und
dann wenn ein livestream wollt schreibt
mir dass er vorne rein
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zu endlich mal wieder einer
weiteren folge minecraft facts und zwar
ist es ja mal relativ ich sage mal
kompliziert diese folgen zu produzieren
vor allem wenn man einfach alle daten
verliert und darunter auch die minecraft
welt dessen alle gespeicherten
kommentare deswegen wenn ihr weitere
effekt zu wissen dann schreibt sie
meldeten die kommentare und nicht so
etwas wie luca wenn man auf einen kaktus
drauf springt dann kriegt man keinen
schaden wenn man's nicht dabei und es
stimmt einfach nicht also es bringt es
nicht wenn ihr mir sachen ich mach das
mal ein bisschen höher hier übrigens
nicht wenn dem defekt sind die
kommentare schreibt die nichts bringen
die die einfach nicht gehen das bringt
dich das dann dumm dann verständig meine
zeit kommt noch viel seltener in folge
also wenn schon vernünftige fans im
kommentare schreiben und ich würds
angefangen direkt an mit dem effekt von
gaming guru 3799 minecraft fake bitte
lesen wenn man auch zombie bildete einen
trank der schwäche wirft und damit einem
goldenen apfel auf diesen rechtsklick
macht vibriert dieser und es gibt ein
explosionsgeräusch das soll so viel ich
weiß der weg sein
der einzige weg sein einen zombie
manager zu einem normalen winter zu
machen ich hoffe du liest das ja ich
hab's gelesen gaming guru hier habe ich
einmal getestet und zwar der vibriert
jetzt ein bisschen das kennt ihr alle
von eurer mutter von einer schublade so
wir wollen natürlich ein gewisses niveau
erhalten
wir sehen hier ein zombie villiger der
weg wie man zombie villiger bekommt im
creative wenn ich selber testen wollt
ist halt ganz einfach auf normal stellen
zombies rogers born und der rest
erledigen die zombies und jetzt werde
ich hier einen ich habe es hier ist
preschen auf mindestens 3 minuten bei
einer pleite - 0 5 hektar mensch also
ich erfinde es da drauf jetzt der
bluttat so ein bisschen hätten im
goldenen apfel drauf machen kommt ein
komischer sounds wird explodieren und
der zid hat ein bisschen das sieht man
es kann jetzt überall machen und die
sollen sich angeblich dann irgendwie
zurück verwandeln sollen in normale
villiger wieder wie genau das
funktionieren soll weiß ich nicht vor
allem wenn ich da dann villagers vorne
dann wird er trotzdem von den leuten
angegriffen und davos verwandt er
überlebt nicht mehr kommt trotzdem
normaler raus also ich weiss nicht
gaming guru das könnte eventuell noch
mal recherchieren ist ja ein guru und
wir das hinter der nächsten folge land
oder unter dieser folge einfach hin
schreiben was genau das bringt wenn die
sowie drehen aber es ist auf jeden fall
witzig und ich weiß nicht was es soll
aber ich denke keiner von euch wusste
dass oder wusstet ihr dass ich weiß ich
schreibe es in die kommentare
ihr könnt mir schreiben ob ihr das mal
musste schreibt sowas einfach mal und
dann den mann vom vermieter der nächste
effekt wurde mir zugesendet von mika
pfister der das wunderschön geschrieben
hat ich habe einen minecraft effekt ein
fake für minecraft ex denn sonst strich
dann wunderschönen alles beschrieben ich
glaube ich muss jetzt nicht beschreiben
kann das thema selbst erklären und zwar
kennen dass wahrscheinlich die meisten
von euch schon allerdings fragen mich
immer wieder leute höhe des kiel als ich
das zum beispiel letztes mal hier oder
höhle gemacht habe und zwar ihr seht die
riesige mengen an greven und anstatt
einfach eure schaufel dafür zu
verschwenden immer einen weg zu grabe
und dann warten bis der rest darunter
fällt hier das dauert ja schon mal ein
momentchen bis das dann alles da ankommt
könnte auch einfach ganz schnell links
und rechts weg machen okay jetzt
vielleicht nicht so schnell nicht so
schnell wie ich aber so dass genau das
eben im fallen das mit einer fahne
fackel dahin setzt weil dann fällt das
alles darauf ob ich bin zum creative so
und dann fällt das halt alles darauf auf
die fackel letzten relativ easy peasy
minecraft weg den ich schon seit der
alpha gibt glaube ich oder seit der beta
ich glaube sogar seit der alpha schon
und da auch noch wieder eine sache ich
hab ja ich lese mir immer verlässlich
kommentare durch ich schreibe immer
leute defekt sind ja vor lauter
konjunktive million ja wenn ich finde
aus der neuesten version nehmen würde
dann wäre das hier die letzte folge und
dann wird dies die serie die
wiederkommen
das sind ja facts die insgesamt ist ja
nicht minecraft 1.7 text heißt ja facts
minecraft facts lachen die eventuell
noch nicht wusstet sowas wohl es kann
auch sein dass sowas hier schon sehr
sehr viele von euch wussten was ich auch
nachvollziehen kann allerdings einige
nicht und diesen einigen habe ich jetzt
geholfen und ihr habt ja auch irgendwie
damals über video erfahren weil website
selbst selbst herausgefunden aber die
die zeit nicht selbst gefallen haben die
sich mal gefragt haben die wissen es
jetzt wenn ihr eine große menge an
travel oder sein seht also sachen die
minecraft schwerkraft haben und runter
fallen könnte da ein
capellos mein handy sagt mich ab morgen
kunst entfällt die das sagt einfach wenn
ihnen fackel und untersetzt ist das
ganze zeugs darauf fällt und sich
trennen und ihr trotzdem die blöcke
bekommt klingt logisch kommen wir weiter
zum dritten akt und zwar es ist ein fakt
der den ihr alle einfach wisst dass ihr
alle schon wahrgenommen hat dank ich
aber ich glaube keiner hat sich darüber
schon mal so richtig gedanken gemacht
und zwar man kann kühe melken
allerdings kann man kühe unendlich oft
hintereinander melken sogar auf dem
multiplayer server können
zehn leute einander zu stehen und alle
können diese kuh melken und diese kuh
wird nicht irgendwie ausgelaugt oder so
die kuh bleibt einfach standhaft stehen
und gibt weiter ihre milch also ich
zeige euch das mal ich drücke ihr name
mannigfaltig du blödmann ich brauch pub
einmal gibt mir im letzten game mode 0
serien zackig zackig zackig sagten wir
nicht sagen wir zahlen will ich zeigen
mich und ich guck mir waren sammelt und
die märkte war nix und dezember klein
kein bisschen kleiner geworden als die
anderen kühe
das ist so abnormal eigentlich müsste
diese kuh tot sein müsste eigentlich gar
keine flüssigkeit mehr im bauch haben
und irgendwann müsste man da die gedärme
raus pumpen
theoretisch wäre das dann hat man keine
milch drin sondern gegen rote kreuz mit
dem damen naja ich muss irgendwie
darunter 18 grenze hier bleiben deswegen
also ist eine sache die weiß jeder
allerdings ist es einfach ein effekt
dass kaltes keine kuh irgendwann aufhört
möglich zu geben die geben einfach immer
weiter milch trinke und checken direkt
neue mitarbeiter das ist so schwierig
diese kuh
dieser enthält milliarden liter milch
ach was milliarden milliarden milliarden
milliarden milliarden und trillionen
eben keine ahnung im oktober geht micro
trilliarden gibt's ja auch noch um mein
gott wenn man sich das vorstellt eine
kuh vor die gibt dann irgendwie doch ein
paar liter und basta und dann macht man
einfach immer weiter und ihm
so und dann kommt auch schon zum fun
fake den ich diesmal nicht vergessen
werden einander ist und zwar übrigens
man ja immer mehr leute zu hören über
von diesem mai kräftig sie gehen über
sieben minuten und du kannst es
eigentlich in einem youtube packen ja
natürlich wenn ich einfach eine flat
world machen würde mit gras drin und so
dann wird das natürlich gehen aber ich
gebe ihm bei jedem einzelnen fact mühe
das heißt für mich die sanieren haus und
ich da design das sogar drin obwohl ich
da gar nicht reingehen muss das werde
ich auch bei den alten folgen
feststellen ich mache immer noch so ein
kleines extra zeigt das nicht einfach
nur ich mache das immer so ein bisschen
schön
ich will ja nicht dass das video noch
eine minute lang geht sondern dass das
halb sieben minuten lang geht oder keine
ahnung wie lange keine ahnung fünf
minuten 1000 minuten irgendwie so dass
ihr euch dann dahin letzten können wir
mit dem café mit plätzchen und dann
könnt ihr euch ein bisschen bilden wegen
lokaler faktoren bringen
das anfang mai und ich möchte euch halt
ein paar sachen beibringen aber nicht
einfach so ja okay ich kann keine
pumpkins hier platzieren so nächster weg
soll das will ich machen
also ich habe hier ein pumpkin und jack
o lantern übrigens wollt ihr das
überhaupt so oder wollt ihr lieber dass
ich wirklich das so schnell machen
gibt man daumen hoch wenn ihr dass sie
so gut finden wenn ich das so machen
sonst kennt meine kommentare schreiben
nichts anders wollt oder er sei
zufrieden damit und mehr schreibt mir
einfach so ich kann keine pumpkins hier
oben in der luft platzieren das ist mir
natürlich schon ein hero aufgefallen
weil ich dachte vielleicht für kmu dass
die tür für ein paar leute ist das
vielleicht auch ganz gut mit jack o
lantern geht das auch nicht sondern ich
kann dir nur hier so platzieren
ich kann dir nur so auf dem boden
platzieren oder an blöcken offen boden
also entweder halt hier direkt auf dem
boden oder da an seinen block dran aber
da geht es nicht darum geht es nicht
darum geht auch nicht auch nicht weil es
halt in der luft ist oder auf blättern
kalt und ja also diese pumpkins können
nur vom boden platziert werden irgendwie
ein bisschen komisch weil sowas wie
blätter hat eigentlich genau die gleiche
konstanz sage ich mal in der konsistenz
heißt es menschen wie beides früchten
fällt eigentlich alles runter oder erde
auf und so was alles und ja ich weiß
nicht mit der schwerkraft in minecraft
muss man ein bisschen vorsichtig sein
und ich würde sagen freude das war's mit
der heutigen folge
maik rosner übrigens freunde wollte
eigentlich dass wir einmal live stream
mache also ich würde dann heute abend
ein bisschen hero stream wieder
wahrscheinlich nur dann eine stunde oder
zwei stunden hero
ich muss mir doch mal durchleben mit den
neuen regeln sind aber berti erstmal
dafür schreiben kommentare ob er ja
schreibt für live stream und mit ganz
vielen die und enden und dann wenn ihr
keinen livestream world schreibt mir
dass der torten rein und dann werde ich
mich da wenn man dran halten und
eventuell schauen ob ich da einen
livestream organisieren kann machen kann
und dann schauen wir uns das man einfach
anderen link steht in der beschreibung
steht auch noch mal hier eingeblendet
ganz fest widge.de von crafter kadaver
draufklicken voller und dann seid ihr
immer auf der richtigen seite kriegt
dafür nichts ich mache auch keine
werbung wenn ihr da trotzdem werbung
sehen solltet ihr das irgendwie von
fitch ich bin da kein partner werde doch
nicht sein und will dass das werbeverbot
frei bleibt und dann will ich damals
euch gefallen habe ich mich über ein
daumen hoch freude könnte weiter infekt
und sachen den kommentare schreiben die
wette wusste wo wir sind